ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะนะหรือเหรียญ
เรียน
ตัว a คะ
ผู้เรียนสำเภอกัดอะไรคะเป็นวันอะไรคะพี่
เอ๋
เหมือนเดิมค่ะวันอาทิเปีย
กูเอกกับผู้เรียนได้เจอกันเฉพาะวัน
อาทิตย์มหาใช่เพราะวันอาทิตย์นี้วันที่
เท่าไหร่คะครูเอ๋วันที่ 12 ค่ะ 12
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มิถุนายนค่ะ
มิถุนายนปีคศอะไรคะซอง
2022 ค่ะ
2022 แล้วปีพศอะไรคะพี่เอ๋ 2
2565  2566
[เพลง]
5i ค่ะตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะ
ตอนนี้ล่ะคะเวลา 10:00 น 13 น
สิบโมง 13 นาทีแล้วค่ะ
ค่ะร้อนมากใช่ที่บ้านของเทียมก็ร้อน
คู๋ไม่มีพักแล้วเนี่ย
หากระดาษหรอกสัตว์
ที่บ้านครูเรียมก็ร้อนใช่ไหมคะบ้านครูเอ
ก็ร้อนมากแล้วก็แอร์เปิดไม่ได้
แกมีน้ำตกลงมา
ติดนี้ก็จะพูดพูดไปอีกแล้วนะเด่นเห็น
เหงือกไหล
จะมีเหงื่อไหลนะโอเคนะคะ
โอเคค่ะผู้เรียนค่ะแล้วอาทิตย์นี้นี้ครู
เลียมมีอะไรมันเล่าให้นักเรียนฟังคะ
มีค่ะเรียงมีเกี่ยวกับความเชื่อของคนที่
อยู่ภาคอีสานของประเทศไทยพูดเอ๋มาที่ภาค
อีสานบ่อยไหมคะ
ไม่บ่อยนะเคยไป
เพราะว่าน่าจะ 4 หรือ 5 ครั้งนะค่ะแต่แต่
เนี่ยได้ยินบ่อยๆเพราะว่าเมื่อก่อนครูเอ๋
เป็นครูก็ที่ทำงานก็จะมีโคครูที่มาจากภาค
อีสาน 1  2  3  4  5  5 5คนมั้งรู้ข้าง
และก็จะมีเพื่อนเพื่อนที่อยู่ภาคอีสานอีก
หลายคน
เพราะว่าเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยว
ค่ะภาคอีสานเนี่ยจะเห็นจะเห็นหนักนี่
คู่เอกกำลังที่เห็นอยู่นัดไปเป็นป่าเป็น
ป่าแล้วก็แล้วมันมีบ้านเล็กๆหรอ
มีบ้านเล็กๆข้างอิสานเนี่ยเขาเรียกว่า
เนินปู่ตา
เดิน
เอามาต้องสูงขึ้นใช่ก็คือจะเป็นพื้นที่
สูงขึ้นอย่าลืมเปลี่ยนสีประการเป็นสี
เขียวแล้วกัน
กี่แดงก็ได้ค่ะคนเอาครีมมันจะเห็นชัดเลย
หนูขึ้น
ไข่เขาเรียกเนินและแต่ไม่ใช่ภูเขาจะถ้า
ไม่ใช่ภูเขาจะสูงกว่าเดินใช่ภูเขาในจะสูง
แล้วก็ใหญ่กว่า
ค่ะเป็นเนินที่จะเป็นเนินสูงขึ้นมานิด
หน่อยแล้วก็
ประมาณ 1 เมตร 2 เมตรได้ไหมคะประมาณ 1
เมตร 2 เมตรก็เป็น Learn แล้วนะคะ
กวางเมตร 2 เมตรสูง 1 เมตร 2 เมตรก็เนิน
ใช่ๆแต่ถ้าเกิดภูเขาในติดใหญ่มาก
ขาด
ตรงนี้เนี่ยทางอีสานถ้าเกิดครูเอ๋หรือว่า
นักเรียนมาที่ภาคอีสานน่าจะเฮง
เห็นบ้านหลังนี้
มีเยอะค่ะที่บ้านหลักอยู่บนเนิน
คิดว่าก็
ไม่ใหญ่ค่ะบ้านน่ะขนาดบ้านบางที่ก็ก็แค่
ประมาณ
1 เมตรประมาณ 1 เมตร x พอเด็กบ้านหรือ
เรียกสารคะทางโน้นเป็นเหมือนบ้านดูเพล็
กซ์ร้ายดูคล้ายๆบ้านแต่ว่าเล็กๆเขาจะ
เรียกสานต่อเพราะว่าที่กูอีกถามว่าไอ้คุย
กับคนเป็นกำลังงง
ว่าถ้าเป็นสารนะถ้าทางภาคกลางก็คือต้องมี
เสามีเสาแล้วก็สูงขึ้นไปแล้วค่อยๆบ้านกับ
ที่ครูเห็นตอนนี้มันเหมือนกับไม่ได้มีมี
เสา 1 เสาแต่ว่าดูเหมือนบ้านเลยนะคะก็เลย
สงสัยว่าที่นู่นเรียกว่าบ้าไอ้เรียกว่า
บ้านเรียกว่าสารหรือเรียกว่าอะไรเรียกว่า
สารค่ะ
เหมือนกันนะคะๆก็ได้เรานี่อุ่นส่วนบ้าน
บ้าน
ศาลปู่ตา
สารภูฏานตาเนี่ยต้องอยู่ในปากแบบนี้ล่ะคะ
ผู้เรียนม
อยู่ในที่ที่ไกลจากบ้านของคนอย่างเช่นอัน
นี้เป็นหมู่บ้านใช่ไหมคะ
หมู่บ้าน
หมู่บ้านบางที่นะศาลปู่ตาจะอยู่ไกล
อันนี้คือศาลปู่ตา
ที่เราเห็นในรูปเนี่ยจะอยู่ไกลจากหมู่
บ้าน
อิฐแล้วอยู่ในป่าด้วยใช่ไหมคะส่วนใหญ่นะ
ประมาณ
80 เปอร์เซ็นต์อยู่ในป่า
อะไรอีก 20%  20% ก็คืออยู่ในหมู่บ้าน
อาเล็กไล่ถ้าคุณแต่ว่ามี 20% ค่ะน้อยมาก
อาจจะเป็นเพราะว่าเดี๋ยวนี้บ้านคนแบบ
เพิ่มมากขึ้นที่ดินแคร์ค่ะก็เลยแบบสร้าง
บ้านใหม่แล้วมือใกล้ๆกับสารปลูกตามมาขึ้น
แล้วเอ่อ
อยู่ที่กูเห็นข่าวอ่ะพี่เค้าต้องอยู่ไกล
หมู่บ้านใช่ไหม
ตัวเองเห็นมีป่าแล้วต้องอยู่ตรงที่เป็น
ป่าด้วยหรือเปล่าคะ
อยู่ตรงเป็นปาบนักเรียนป่าก็คือที่มีต้น
ไม้ต้นไม้เยอะๆที่เน็ตภาพของครูเรียมนะ
ค่ะเรียกว่าป่านะคะใช่แล้ว
คู่เอกก็ไม่รู้นะได้ยินพี่ที่ทำงานน่ะบอก
ว่าอ่ะที่ภาคอีสานในไม่ใช่ในเมืองท่าใน
เมืองครูเอไม่ทราบนอกเมืองนะอ.เมืองก็คือ
ตรงที่เค้าปลูกข้าวนะครับปลูกข้าวทำนาเขา
ก็จะมีมีบ้านที่แบบทุเรียนบอกมีบ้านบ้าน
บ้านๆเป็นหมู่บ้านหมู่บ้านเดี๋ยวคุยเองขอ
ใช้สกรีนได้ไหมคะคุณเรียม
ได้
เคครับบอกว่าคืนเขาจะแบ่งเป็นหมู่บ้าน
หมู่บ้านใช่ไหมคะถ้าถ้าสมมติวันที่นี้
เป็นหมู่บ้านที่นี่
หมู่บ้านปริหมูอ่านก็คือมีบ้านบ้านหลายๆ
บ้าน
ก็เป็นหมู่บ้านอาจจะ 50
50 ครอบครัวทำไม่แน่ใจนะคะประมาณนี้ตรง
นี้ก็อาจจะมีหมู่บ้านเอื้อ
คะ
แล้วก็จะมีทางเข้าหมู่บ้าน
อันไม่อาจจะมีทางเข้า
บางทีไม่ใช่ถนนก็ได้นะคะนักเรียนเป็นทาง
ที่แบบคนเดินเข้าได้หรือรถเข้าได้เขาก็
บอกว่าจะมีป่าตรงเนี้ยตรงนี้ก็อาจจะมีป่า
ป่าก็คือมีต้นไม้
ต้นไม้แบบนี้
ใช่ไหมนี้ก็มีต้นไม้นะคะมันหมายสีเขียวดี
กว่าเนาะ
[เพลง]
แล้วก็จะมี
เนินนะคะ
คุณเรียมว่าได้
คือแต่ละหมู่บ้านเขาจะมีของเขาใช่ไหมคะ
คุณใช่ค่ะแต่ละหมู่บ้านรัชชาเกิด
หรือว่าบางที่น่ะเนินปูด r11 เนี่ยก็มี
หลายๆหมู่บ้านที่มาไหว้ขอ
ถ้าเป็นหมู่บ้านที่ใกล้จังฉันไม่ไปหาล่ะ
อย่าคิด
เหมือนที่ที่แถวบ้านหมูอัดอ๋อโอเคแถวบ้าน
เหลี่ยมเรือนค่ะมีเนินปู่ตานึงที่หลาย
หมู่บ้านมากคิดว่า
คิดว่าประมาณ
10 หรือ 20 หมู่บ้านนะที่มาไหว้เนี่ย
ประมาณ 20 หมู่บ้านมาว่าและและเป็นแล้ว
เป็นตาแบบนี้ไหมคะขึ้นอีกคือมีต้นไม้เยอะ
ๆหากมีต้นไม้เยอะๆแล้วก็อยู่ไกลไกลจาก
หมู่บ้าน
เดี๋ยวจะให้ดูขนาด
ขนาดสารก็อ่าโอ้โหเหมือนเป็นบ้านจริงๆเลย
อ่ะไม่คล้ายๆบ้านแต่ว่าหลังเล็กกว่า
คนอยู่ได้นะคะข้างในเนี่ยคนอยู่ไม่ได้
ไปนอน
หมายถึงว่าขนาดของศาลคนออนได้ไหมดูแล้วก็
กว้างอยู่นะ
แต่ไม่มีใครกล้านอนอ่ะไงก็นอนค่ะ
เอาจริงๆก็มันเล็กคิดว่าเล็กเกินไปค่ะครู
เอ๋นอนก็ไม่ได้นะ
ค่ะนั่นแหละแล้วคนที่ที่เขากำลังว่ายอยู่
ในรูปนะคะค่ะสารเนี่ยเขาเรียกว่าพระเจ้า
คือใคร
มีภาคกลาง
ภาษาภาคกลางมันเป็นโป้ขาของกี่สารนะของ
ทางอีสานเขาเรียกคะจ้ำก็คือคนที่จะไปพูด
พูดพูดพูดกับศาลปู่ตาถ้าเกิดเป็นเรียมไป
ศาลปู่ตาเตรียมก็ไหว้สาธุเฉยๆนะแต่ว่าคน
ที่เป็นค่ะนิค่ะจำประจำ
แต่ว่าเออบางจังหวัดเขาเรียกหมอทำ
หมอตามจังหวัดนะบางจังหวัดก็เรียบ
ไม่ใช่หมอนะคะนักเรียนไม่ใช่ไม่สบายหรอ
หมอทำอะไรนะครับทำทำมันมันศาสนาพุทธธรรม
มะอาหารก็คือเป็นคนที่มีความรู้ว่าจะพูด
กับวิญญาณยังไงใช่ไหมคะใช่ๆอะไรนะคะจั้ม
นะคะจำทางทางอีสานนะเรียกค่ะจั้มค่ะ
ถ้าเป็นผู้ชายเหรอคะหรือผู้หญิงก็ได้ชาย
บ้านประตูมีแบบผู้ชายผู้ชายทุกคนเลย
แล้วค่ะจำเขาจะทำอะไรคะค่าจ้างสิริ
ปกติเนี่ยเขาก็จะเป็นคนที่อยู่ที่
3 แถวๆศาลจุดตานะคะแล้วก็เวลาเราไปไหว้
เนี่ยเขาก็จะเป็นคนพูดกับศาลปู่ตาเรา
เนี่ยเป็นคนบอกขัดเป็นคนบอกหมอทำหรือบอก
ค่ะจำอีกทีนึงแล้วหมอทำหรือคะเจ้าเนี่ยก็
จะพูดกับสารตูดตา
เราพูดตรงๆไม่ได้ไม่ค่ะ
พูดตรงๆไม่ได้เขาจะมีว่างๆเขาจะมีพูดพูด
พูดอะไรของเขานี่แหละ of บทสวด
ก็เรียกบทสวดที่เราถ้าไม่เข้าใจนะใครใช่
ค่ะ
เวลาที่เรียมขับรถนะขับรถขาด 3 จุดตาล
เหลี่ยมก็จะว่ายนะ
ค่ะไหว้ศาลปู่ตาหรือว่า
เรียงเดือนค่ะ
ๆๆๆขับรถผ่านแล้วเลียมไหว้นักใครจับพวง
อะไร
แต่ว่าจอดก่อน
แล้วก็ทำพวงมาลัยอยู่ก็แบบเอาเอาแบบเขา
เรียกว่าอะไรนะหัวลงดีกับเราได้เพราะผิด
แต่ก้ม
หัวแล้วก็บีบแต่
กี่ครั้ง
ประมาณ 3 ครั้งกี่ครั้ง
3 ครั้งต่างๆๆ
[เพลง]
สวัสดี 3
ไม่ใช่มันเป็นการบอก
บ่ปู่ตาว่าเดี๋ยวเราจะเดินทางจะขับรถไกล
มากอาจจะไปเชียงใหม่ไปกรุงเทพฯ
แต่ตัวเองสงสัยไหมคะว่าอุดตันให้กำลังจะ
ถามเนี้ยใช่ก็มันจะถามว่าไปไหว้ใครปู่ตา
เป็นใครทำไมต้องไหว้กับอา
หารเยอะค่ะ
ทำไมต้องไหว้แล้วทำไมต้องมีอันนี้แล้ว
ทำไมทุกคนไปว่าอย่างเงี้ยคุณปู่ตามเอา
เข้าจริงๆนะคะเรียมที่บ้านครูเอ๋อ่ะที่
ใหม่อ่ะค่ะคือบ้านกูเองอยู่ชลบุรีแล้วก็
บ้านเก่าไม่มีเรามีแค่ศาลพระภูมิธรรมดา
แบบเพราะคู๋ย้ายบ้านห่างจากบ้านเก่า
ประมาณสักสองสามกิโลเมตร
แล้วก็ยายบ้านก็หมู่บ้านเขาก็มีคล้ายๆกัน
แบบนี้ค่ะคุยนะอะไรอ่ะปีทุกคนจะต้องไป
ไหว้ใช่กับวันหยุดอยู่ในหมู่บ้านอยู่ใน
หมู่บ้านเลยกูเอกกะรู้สึกแปลกๆทำไมอะไร
เขาก็บอกว่าเป็นสารกลางบ้านแถวนั้นก็เลข
ศาสตร์กลางบ้านก็คือคล้ายๆกันนี่แหละศาล
ปู่ตากูเอง
ทำไมมีอะไรมีแต่ว่าคนตรงนั้นคนที่บ้าน
บ้านคุยเป็นบ้านไทยจีนใช่ไหมคะทำงั้นกู
เองก็ไม่รู้ว่าเป็นคือชลบุรีมีไทยไทยจีน
ไทยลาวเป็นเราส่งตื่นก็เลยไม่แน่ใจว่าสาร
ตรงเนี้ยไม่เป็นสารสารของไทยข้างของไทย
ไม่นี่นะแต่ถ้าเป็นไทยลาวและจะมี
ไทยลาวก็เลยงงๆแต่ว่าแต่งตัวที่ทำศาลก็
คล้ายๆถ่าย
ยังไม่เคยร้านอาหารอะไร
แต่จันทร์ที่บ้านก็ไปไหว้วันกันคล้ายๆ
โคเรียมแล้วนะคะที่เราทำไมมีน่ะที่สงสาร
เป็นสารของเขาเรียกบรรพบุรุษนะมันเข้าไป
อยู่ก็มีคนที่แบบเกิดแก่แล้วก็ตายไปแล้ว
ตายไปนานมาก
พูดง่ายๆก็คือพ่อของพ่อของพ่อของพ่อของ
พ่อใช่อันนี้ครูเรียมมีคุณพ่อก็จะมีคุณ
พ่อของคุณพ่อแล้วก็คุณพ่อของคุณพ่อแล้วก็
คุณพ่อของคุณพ่อ
อุ้ยก็คือมีพ่อมีปู่ใช่ไหมคะปู่หรือมีแม่
มีตาพ่อของแม่คือคุณตาพ่อของพ่อคือคุณปู่
และเนี่ยคือคุณปู่คุณตาเพราะว่าพ่อกับแม่
มาแต่งงานกันแล้วพ่อของพ่อเป็นคนปู่พอ
ก่อนแม่เป็นของงไม่นักเรียน
งงไว้เตรียมว่าพ่อแม่ให้หน่อยดิพ่อแม่อัน
นี้อันนี้เตรียมนะอันนี้เรียนแล้วก็มีพ่อ
มีแม่เนาะ
พ่อแม่ก็มีพ่อแม่ให้พ่อก็มีพ่อมีแม่
แม่ก็มีพ่อแล้วก็มีแม่
ค่ะพ่อของเค้าเนี่ยเรียกว่าปู่ใช่ไหมคะ
เข้าข้อเนี่ยเรียกว่าปลูกเพราะของแม่คือ
พ่อของแม่คือตา
รับพ่อของปู่
ยังมีพ่อของอยู่ใช่พ่อของพ่อปู่
ใช่
พ่อของพ่อของพ่อปู่นั่นล่ะค่ะนักเรียนบอล
พบ
หลุดที่นักเรียนและทั้งหมดนี้คือหลุดวัน
พระบุรุษ
คือคือคือไม่อยู่แล้วนะคะถ้าเราพูดคำว่า
บรรพบุรุษเคเค้าเสียชีวิตไปแล้วใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ใช่ค่ะแล้วอันนี้เป็นสารของบรรพบุรุษ
ใช่ค่ะเป็นสารของบรรพบุรุษที่แถวบ้านของ
เดียวเนี่ยที่มีหลายหมู่บ้านที่เรียงบอก
ไปว่าประมาณ 20 หมู่บ้าน
20 หมู่บ้านเนี้ยมาไหว้เพราะว่าปู่ตา
เนี่ยอยู่ในตำแหน่งที่สูงของประเทศไทยณ
ประเทศไทยหรือเปล่าสมัยก่อนก็คือเหมือนทำ
งาน
ทำงานเหมือนเขาเรียกว่าอะไรนะ
ตำแหน่งที่ศูนย์ถ้าเกิดถ้าเกิดอยู่นอก
เมืองเป็นเจ้าเมืองล่ะคะยังในถ้าเกิดอัน
นี้เป็นเจ้าเมืองใช่ไหมของมหาสารคามที่
จังหวัดมหาสารคามจะมีก้าวเมืองที่แบบอยู่
สูงที่สุดของสารคามแต่ว่าอุทาคนเนี่ยจะ
อยู่กับลำดับรองลงมารองลงมาอยู่ตรงนี้ของ
เจ้าเมืองก็เลยแบบนี้คนไปไหว้เยอะมากๆ
ใช่แล้วอะไรจำชื่อใช่อื้ออ่าหลวงจังว่าง
อออ
ขอได้คือเข้าใจตำแหน่ง
สูง
ค่ะใช่ค่ะแล้วนะคุณแม่เลี้ยงรู้ไหมคะครู
เอ๋ว่านอกจากจะไปไหว้แล้วอ่ะเวลาที่เรา
อยู่บ้านเราก็ขอขอให้ปู่ตาช่วยเราได้นะ
เดี๋ยวที่บอกไปว่ายเนี่ยก็คือไปว่าให้
เพื่อให้ช่วยเราอ่ะ
ว่ามันมันจะเป็นอย่างนี้ค่ะคือเราอยู่
บ้านของเราเนี่ยแล้วเราก็ค่ะ
เรียมจะไปเชียงใหม่เตรียมอยากขับรถดีๆ
เลี้ยงก็คิดคิดถึงปู่ตาแล้วก็บอกกูตาขอ
ให้เรียมขับรถดีๆนะ
อ๋อขับรถปลอดภัยไม่ชนใช่ก็คือคิดรถอยู่
ไหนก็ได้อยู่ที่บ้านก็ได้หรือว่าอยู่ที่
เชียงใหม่อยู่ที่กรุงเทพฯก็ได้เรียนก็จะ
คิดแล้วก็ไหว้ขอให้ปู่ตาดูแลขอให้ขับรถดี
ๆ
หรือว่า
ส่วนใดก็ขออะไรกันน่ะขอ
ขอขับรถดีๆขอทำงานดีๆ
อาจขอให้แข็งแรงไหมใช่ค่ะขอให้แข็งแรง
แล้วครูเธอรู้ไหมคะเวลาที่ขออย่างเช่น
เตรียมไปเชียงใหม่เตรียมขับรถไปเชียงใหม่
แม่เรือนก็จะไหว้ที่บ้านนะแล้วก็ขอบอกว่า
ขอให้เรียมขับรถปลอดภัย
แล้วแม่ถ้าเกิดเรียมกลับมาที่บ้านแล้ว
โอเคปลอดภัยขับรถไม่ชนแม่ก็จะเอาถ่ายเอา
ไก่ไปเลี้ยง
เอาไก่ไปเลี้ยงคือคือเอาไก่
ต่อเป็นไก่ไก่ต้มนะที่เห็นอ่ะเลี้ยงก็คือ
เอาไปให้กินกูเอกหนูเอาเพราะว่าไก่เอาไป
เลี้ยงเอาไก่ไปแล้วก็จ่ายยังไม่ได้หรือ
เปล่าไปเลย
เอาไปเลี้ยงคือเอาไปให้ไปให้ไข่ให้ไข่คะ
ให้ที่ศาลปู่ตา
ต้องบอกพูดเอาไว้ก่อนถ้าจะให้ใช่ค่ะต้อง
บอกไปก่อน
เราจะเราจะอยู่อยู่ที่ไหนก็ได้แค่เราคิด
แล้วก็ไหว้แล้วก็พูดแต่ว่าเวลาเลี้ยง
เนี่ยต้องไปที่ศาล
ต้องไปเลี้ยงที่สัตว์
ก็ไปวางไก่ไว้ที่ 3
แล้วนอกจากนั้นค่ะคุณเอ๋ค่ะเวลาที่เรียม
ซื้อซื้อรถยนต์
ซื้อรถยนต์
หรือว่าซื้อรถมอเตอร์ไซค์
เหมือนเนี่ย
ค่ะหนูเล่นนะคะ
เรียงก็จะ
บอก
ว่ายบอกปู่ตาด้วยนะคะคะแล้วก็บอกว่า
บอกว่าเรียงซื้อรถคันนี้
เลขทะเบียน
ขอให้ปู่ตาดูแลให้ปลอดภัยไม่ชน
ผีไม่มา
ใช่เราก็ขับรถไปใกล้ๆกับศาลปู่ตาแล้วก็
บอกกูตาแล้วก็บิดแต่
เย้
รถใหม่ซื้อรถสบายใจแล้ว
ซื้อมอเตอร์ไซค์ก็เหมือนกัน
ก็ไปบอกถูกตาบอกค่ะแลไม่ให้ชน
คนทำแบบนั้นนะคะทุเรียนใช่ค่ะทุกๆคนแถว
บ้านเรียมนะ
ทำแบบนั้นแต่ฮะคนที่มาจากกรุงเทพฯคนที่มา
จากจังหวัดอื่นอาจจะแบบนี้ทำอะไรเหมือน
ที่ครูเอ๋คิดก็อาจจะไม่ได้ทำอะไรทำไมต้อง
ทำเอไม่ทำได้มั้ยใช่ๆใช่ก็จะสงสัยก็เลย
ไม่ทำแต่ว่าคนที่บ้านอยู่ที่นี่มาตั้งนาน
แล้วก็จะไปไหว้ก็จะไปกอดแล้วใน 1e  1 ปี
ก็จะมีเลี้ยงปู่ตางานอย่างไม่น้อยนะ 1  3
เป็นงานเลี้ยงที่ทุกคนต้องมาใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะ
ทุกๆคนต้องการ
ทำอาหารไปด้วยนะคะใช่ทำอาหารไปด้วยส่วน
หน้าที่ละอาหารเยอะนะ
อะไรนะมาตย์มีหลายภาษาช่วงค่ะอ่าน
อาหารส่วนใหญ่เป็นอะไรคะหรือว่าต้องเป็น
ไก่แบบที่ครูเตรียมบอกอาหารส่วนใหญ่เป็น
ไก่ค่ะพี่เอามาเนี่ยเป็นไก่ไก่ต้ม
แล้วก็มีข้าวเหนียว
อันนี้ข้าวเหนียวค่ะ
มีผลไม้ด้วยไหมคะผลไม้ที่เห็นในรูปนะคะก็
คือส้มค่ะ
ใช่
เราก็มีอันนี้
เราหายชะลอมอาอุ่นๆป่ะ
ลิปุปะได้หรือว่าเรียกเล่าหายก็ได้
ใช่
ใน 1 ปีหน้าจะมีงานเลี้ยงสารตื่นตาก็คือ
เอาอาหาร
มาถวายปลุกดู
คลิปคนมาเยอะๆจะเป็นช่วงสงกรานต์
[เพลง]
ก็เป็นปกติที่สงกรานต์จะไหว้ไหว้
บรรพบุรุษที่ครูเรียมบอกคือบรรพบุรุษมา
ก่อนใช่เราก็เหมือนกับว่ายเหมือนตอนที่
เขายังมีชีวิตอยู่ตอนที่ยังไม่ตายเราก็ไป
ไหว้ตอนสงกรานต์ใช่ไหมคะถึงตอนนี้
บรรพบุรุษเราหลายๆคนตายไปแล้วเราก็ไปไหว้
เหมือนเดิมเหมือนเดิมเลย
เราก็จะมี
แล้วก็จะมีการรำ
รำ
ทำให้ดูกันนำถวายค่ะ
ที่กับพี่เอกกำลังสงสัยว่าแสดงว่าปู่ตา
คือคนที่เริ่มต้นทำหมู่บ้านนี้หรือเปล่า
คะอ่ะก็
อาจจะทางผ่านเป็นทหารมากค่ะคุณได้อาจจะ
แบบไม่อยู่โอเค
ทีได้ยินว่านักเรียนครูเอกได้ยินนะคะจริง
ไม่จริงไม่ทราบเอกก็ฟังจากเพื่อน
ครูที่เป็นคนรักภาคอีสานเขาบอกว่าอ้ะมัน
เหมือนกับคนบรรพบุรุษอะที่เดินทางมาเดิน
ทางมาบริเวณนี้เราก็เริ่มต้นขุดดินบ้าน
ใช่ไหมคะขุดดินตัดต้นไม้แล้วก็สร้างเป็น
หมู่บ้านมหาเขาก็เวลาสร้างปั๊บและคือทาง
นู้นอ่ะเขาก็เชื่อเรื่องเชื่อเรื่องผีล้อ
ซื้อรำผีนะคะเป็นส่วนหนึ่งก็คือว่าแต่ละ
คนก็จะมีผีปู่ตาของตัวเอง
เงินหัวหน้าค่ะทีมที่ผ่านคนเดินทางมาจน
ถึงที่ดินตรงเนี้ยบริเวณนี้น่ะก่อนจะ
สร้างบ้านเขาก็จะต้องเหมือนกับว่ายใช่ไหม
คะเพราะเขาก็เชื่อว่าบนพื้นดินตรงนั้นก็
มีวิญญาณมีอะไรด้วยฉะนั้นแนวเขาก็ไม่รู้
ล่ะเป็นใครก็จะไหว้แล้วก็
เชิญปู่ตาของตัวเองรหัสของตัวเองอยู่ที่
นี่อยู่ๆเพราะว่าถ้าเราจะไปขุดดินหรือครู
เอ๋ไม่แน่ใจนะอาจจะเชิญวิญญาณที่อยู่ใน
ที่ดินบริเวณนั้นที่เราจะทำบ้านให้มาอยู่
ที่ 3 เพราะว่าถ้าเราไปขุดดินไปตัดต้นไม้
แล้วเราไปตัดต้นไม้ที่มีวิญญาณอยู่ที่ต้น
ไม้น่ะเขาก็จะโกรธได้ใช่ไหมคะเขาก็จะเชิญ
จะต้องมีคนที่รู้ภาษาหมอเขาเรียกรู้วิชา
สวดมนต์อ่ะกูเองก็ฟังไม่เข้าใจก็จะเชิญ
วิญญาณทั้งหลายและมาอยู่ในศาลตอนแรกคุยกะ
เองหรือว่าเป็นคนที่ 1 คนแรกเลยที่มาอยู่
หมู่บ้านนี้เราก็ตายแล้วก็อยู่ที่นี่กับ
พี่เขาบอกว่ามันไม่ใช่เพราะว่าเออเราจะ
ต้องมีมีวินอานที่ดูแลหมู่บ้านเขาเขาชื่อ
ว่าปู่ตาคือวิญญาณที่จะบดหมู่บ้านใน
บริเวณนี้นะใกล้จะมีวิญญาณของปลุกกูตา
เนี่ยแปลไม่ให้ผีจากที่อื่นเข้าหมู่บ้าน
สมุดว่าอย่างครูเรียมอยู่อะไรนะสารคามใช่
ไหมคะถ้าครูเรียมมามาสุรินทร์แล้วเจอ
วิญญาสุรินทร์ติดรถไปด้วย
มีฟองคูเรียมเข้าหมู่บ้านครูเรียนสวัสดี
ปู่ตาปูดตาก็จะออกไปไม่ให้วิญญาณอ่ะเข้า
ไปในหมู่บ้าน
เอาไว้ถ้าปัญญาพรุ่งนี้เข้าไปหมู่บ้านคน
อาจจะไม่สบายได้หรือว่ามีอันตรายถึงพี่คน
เราไปฟังนะคะเขาเชื่อว่าแบบนั้นใช่เหมือน
กันไหมแถวบ้านผู้เรียนคิดว่าคล้ายๆนะคะ
เหมือนที่
ที่ที่ของแม็กขอบเท่ามาเขาเขาเขาเอามาจาก
แบบต้นไม้หรือว่าจากพื้นที่แล้วก็คิดขึ้น
มาว่ามีปัญญาอยู่ที่นั่นแล้วก็คาไปอยู่
ที่ศาลแต่ว่าบางที่อ่ะเขาก็มีแบบมีแบบ
เป็นคนที่ตายไปแล้วจริงๆแล้วก็รู้ว่าเป็น
ไข้แล้วก็คิดว่าคนนี้แหละมาช่วยดูแลมา
ช่วยดูแลให้น้องตอนแรกนะตัวเองเคยเข้าใจ
ว่าออที่เนี่ยเป็น 8 ช้าเวลา
ก่อนตายรักไว้จะเอาไปไว้ที่นั่นกูอีกเข้า
ใจแบบนั้นนะเข้าใจแบบนั้นเพราะว่าสมัย
ก่อนนู้นอาจจะยังไม่มีวัดไงจ๊ะ 500 ปีที่
แล้วอ่ะ 500 ปีที่แล้วอาจจะยังไม่มีวัดก็
น่าจะมีคนตายก็ก็ต้อง
ฝังใช่ไหมคะอ่าฝังกูเอกก็เข้าใจว่าน่าจะ
เป็นคนตาย 500 ปีที่แล้ว 700 ปีที่แล้ว
แล้วอยู่ใต้ดินหรือเปล่าอันนี้คุณเอกคิด
เองนะคะคิดเองแต่แต่ก็ยังไม่ได้มีคำตอบ
ตรงนี้มานะเพราะกูเอกเข้าใจวะไม่มีวัด
เวลามีคนตายก็เลยเอาไปไว้ในในเข้าเรียก
อะไรนะป่าของหมู่บ้าน
ทุเรียนเคยขออะไรไหมคะเคยขอมั้ยหรอ
เคยนะคะเป็นก็ไปไหว้ขอให้
ขอให้แบบทุกๆคนแข็งแรง
เหนื่อย
มามากแล้วก็ทุกคนแข็งแรงดีทุกคนแข็งแรงดี
ค่ะไปถึงพ่อพ่อพ่อกับแม่ของเตรียมแล้วก็
แบบจะมีหมามีควายอะไรเงี้ยแล้วก็บอกให้
ทุกๆคนเลยนะแข็งแรง
ใช่แค่นั้นเองค่ะเราก็สบายใจเราสบายใจก็
โอเคแล้ว
ค่ะก็เป็นความเชื่อเนาะเป็นความเชื่อของ
คนข้างๆอีสาอ่าที่ในแต่ละหมู่บ้านหรือ
หลายๆหมู่บ้านก็จะมีศาลปู่ตาหรือจะเป็น
ป่าของหมู่บ้านก็จะมีสาธุตาไม่ป่ากัด
เดี๋ยวเราต้องการนักเรียนอยากรู้เพิ่มก็
ก็มาประเทศไทยใช่นะค่ะ
วันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนจริงๆแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋หมด
เลยนะฮ่าๆก็สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะบ๊ายบายค่ะ
นักเรียนได้บ้างอ่ะ